another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the scp foundation dr bride  cannot use my evil twin did it as a  viable excuse the same goes for my good  twin did it considering the implication  weirder things have happened at the scp  foundation than having an evil twin so  maybe someone could make the excuse that  their evil twin committed some crimes on  their behalf but the bride family is one  of the most well-known dynasties in  foundation history so nobody is going to  believe that there's a hidden member of  the family still out there maybe if  scp-963 had a perfect copy you might  have an excuse here but to the best of  our knowledge that is not the case take  your lumps jack